les municipales l'occasion de voir
passer quelques candidatures disons
original car pour ces élections tout le
monde à partir de 18 ans peut constituer
une liste
voici quelques précédents multiplier les
jours fériés regarder les fleurs
s'épanouir sont quelques-uns des
éléments du programme de la liste
rires en 1983 le rire le rassemblement
invraisemblable pour le rire est l'
équilibre est l'une des quatre listes de
la commune de plaintel près de saint
brieuc alors la course à la mairie ça
vous fait flipper ça vous fait fantasmer
là oui non oui non la course oui la
mairie mois maintenant il est certain
que ça me fait plaisir ça me ferait
plaisir c'est je voyais une bonne partie
de plats tels ceux du corps ce type est
un peu après le rire voici en 1989 la
liste sourire à mort est dans le jura
cette liste composée de commerçants et
de sportifs a créé la surprise en
recueillant 12,6 pour cent des voix sa
principale proposition était de déplacer
les réunions du conseil municipal dans
les bistrots pour développer le commerce
local
douze ans plus tard autres élections
municipales et autres liste originale en
2001 les motiver se présentait à
toulouse les motiver
c'est au départ un collectif de
chanteurs et de musiciens toulousains
dont zebda prendre la parole la donner à
ceux qui n'en use est pas tel était le
programme démotivés alors pourquoi
motivé parce qu'il ya une spontanéité
dans la société civile qui vous qui doit
s'organiser qui doit se créer
grâce à ses idées le groupe avait
réalisé un score de 12,49 % et obtenait
alors quatre conseillers municipaux à
toulouse en 2008 pierre guiraud lui se
revendiquait du parti coluche schiste en
référence à l'humoriste
il faisait campagne avec dérision mais
briguait très sérieusement la mairie de
lodève dans l'hérault sur ma liste j'ai
déjà compétente j'ai une psychologue
j'ai un gars que je la paye de 700
personnes faut pas croire parce que je
fume à candidatures sur l'humour que
derrière il ya pas du sérieux avec son
humour et son sérieux le coluche schiste
avait tout de même réuni 8,2 pour cent
des voix et pour finir voici pour les
municipales 2014 une candidature
imminente croissance sera bien
croissance revient parmi les tiens à
lille
un comédien à la tête de la liste de
l'église de la très sainte consommation
faisait face à martine aubry une liste
sérieuse mais encore une fois avec
beaucoup d'humour
je sui alessandro di giuseppe le pape 40
de l'église de la très sainte
consommation venu sur terre pour semer
la bonne parole travail obéit console le
pack 40 ne réussit pas à détrôner
martine aubry sa philosophie n'avait
convaincu que trois points 55% des
lillois
[Musique]